as simple as it may seem
SuperMario makers robust toolset has
proven time and again that it has an
impressive level creator it's even
powerful enough to create a working
calculator that can solve simple
equations the cluttered chaos calculator
was created by user giant and it can
work out simple math equations the
calculator only solves 6 plus 6 in the
video and it may not be the most
efficient calculator but it's still
pretty damn cool to use the calculator
mario must hit the blocks with a
corresponding number walk through the
pipe and sit back as he's pushed through
an elaborate circuit maze if you're
curious to see how giant pulled this
feat off you can check out a post he
made on reddit where he breaks down some
of the intricacies the Creator has also
provided an image that illustrates the
logic behind the creation this isn't the
first calculator created with the Mario
maker toolset but it is the first that
has decimal conversions in a proper
display if you want to test out the
calculator yourself the level code is
below and for more on Super Mario maker
stay tuned to game spot